i do have something to talk to you about
sona and this is an
actual concern of mine okay um
and uh i think our audience is aware
that sona is
very pregnant now with twin boys yes
and you are going to be bringing them
into the world
uh any week now any week any time yeah
um and i'm gonna be very honest about
this is not a bit this is actually
something i felt a little bit
uh i am a middle child in a family of
six and
uh in my family i could often feel a
little bit lost in the shuffle oh
which can happen and now for 11 years
you've worked for me
12. um i said worked
so um no you've been with me uh for 12
years
yes i was your priority you didn't
always act like it
but i was your no but i was your
priority and now
yeah that priority i think is going to
shift
because think i think it's going to
shift when these
twin boys show up you think
it's going to shift i have yes
i believe that that's a possibility you
think there's still a chance
you are going to be my biggest priority
in life yeah your best case scenario
is that there's one twin then you then
another twin
priority i don't that's not gonna happen
i just don't know i i feel
some of the same feelings that i felt
back
in you know the early 70s when
uh my youngest brother justin was born
uh he was the sixth and i remember
feeling another one
i'm shoved more into obscurity and of
course they made a big deal about justin
and my father was like oh justin's gonna
be the smart one
and justin will be the good one and uh
i remember feeling it was a tough time
that watergate was happening
uh the country was still recovering from
uh the vietnam war and then
i of course uh plunged more into
obscurity with with each additional
child
now you're putting me through the same
trauma by having twins
and i'm wondering how i'm going to
figure into your life once the twins
show up well first of all
you're a man in your 50s now um late 40s
let's say
no it's definitely not definitely
40's no it's a man in my early 40's
the fact that you still have these
feelings is uh troubling
but also you know you're right for a
long time
i was single i was having a good time
like you were having a really good time
okay relax
and then and then tak came in the
picture and i'm sorry
but tack my husband is also a bigger
priority to me is he really yes
he's my spouse he's my life partner
but i pay you no that's not how life
works it's like liza
is a bigger priority to you you know and
that's how
family works i don't know why i'm
excited
can you tell me what you think in in
terms of rank
priority like what's the priority list
in my life what do you think it is show
business first
oh boy i'm just telling you what my
that's how i wake me up in the middle of
the night and go there's been there's
trouble and i'll say
what the show podcast what's the problem
okay that's what i do just wake me up in
the middle of the night
oh no something terrible happened what
my career what
then i'll start asking questions about
children and wives and
parents and stuff like that what do you
think the list is in my life like
how do you think you rank i understand
having to have
close to similar billing with tack but i
would think the order should be
me tack very close second huh
podcast children oh my god
so the way i see it now is it's okie
first
my dog what yes oh my god this is
hilarious so you're both crazy
you know what i love she's all about her
dog she carries her dog around she's one
of those people that's like oh
okay just had an idea i could tell oh
did you hear what oaky did last night
what'd he do he was thirsty so i put out
water and he drank it
isn't that a good story no that's that's
the kind of [ __ ] that sona's always
saying
and i keep telling her when these twins
show up
you're going to forget your dog you just
are
because that's what happens and you
refuse to believe me
i think you guys are both too close to
it you're too in the thick of it i think
the
natural priority order is your two twin
sons
yeah your husband your dog me
conan
[Laughter]
so who's our guest today i feel like
it's 1973 all over again
okay you were 10. now you're
in your late 50s no i was 10 then but
still somehow i'm only in my late 30s
listen i'm working on my publicist on a
new date of birth we'll get to that
very soon